i'm going to play brigham because this
could be
this could be interesting brigham's
challenging me from position
and what is this
what is this oh this is one of those
like weird
i'm black oh no
it's one of these ah i posted a video
like um what was it over a year ago
it was called stockfish doesn't
understand this position
so if we look at this i'm black i'm up
can i count
i can't count i have eight queens white
has one queen
so i'm up seven queens and a couple more
rooks and so many pawns
the problem is none of these things
actually are doing anything
because pawns are blocking everything so
i'm basically just down a queen
and i'm about to get crushed
oh no instead of finding a career coach
i thought id
find a chess coach good move
flagging in life
sounds like maybe you have to manage
your time better but
it helps out mentors in different types
of areas not just
not just in chess or career
but both could be useful okay let's
focus
i don't want to lose this
i'm trying to figure out my strategy
like this spawns attack so i have to do
something i have to either take take or
play c6
really no other move to consider
i think i'll play c6
and then leave the tension
i'm this is so claustrophobic i guess
white should be claustrophobic too
white can never really take anything
because then my pieces will escape
ah but white has an extra back ring to
work with
that's so sad maybe i'll just close the
whole board
no that's not a good strategy oh thank
you for
the resub togor
the bishop wants to be here i don't know
how i'm going to survive this
maybe f no f6
ah i feel so stuck in life
maybe i have to find a chess coach
teach me how to deal with this position
okay let's play this move
it's a sad move because i can play f6
f6 bam oh we'll try and make do
another big problem like if we get some
end game
um i can never promote like if i get the
pawn to
let's say squares f3 uh it just then
it's just stuck
so on the other hand white can promote
stuff
okay i'll take with this pawn freeing up
the d7 square
this position does make me grateful for
having
at least a single square to develop a
minor piece
like sometimes when you play normal
chest you don't realize how
grateful you should be for having
squares for your pieces
oh thank you stratomaniac
yeah if you're just joining this is uh
not a completely real chess game
um
but we're learning as we go
um now i can't really develop because
the pieces are tied down
to defending everything
i'm gonna just have to leave the tension
and and create some new tension
oh brigham 1700
i don't think i'm going to survive this
i am curious like if we
if we put this position into stockfish
we'll just count the queens and say
black is winning or will it realize that
black is just dead
the last time
[Music]
i think in my previous video stockfish
just didn't
understand it gave like a a plus 60
advantage to black
i feel slightly more free because now
yeah this bishop is
interesting
oh i can take a free rook actually
but do i want to take a free rook i
probably do
[Music]
okay please i got some material i love
your content
and you're genuinely hilarious three
oh you're genuinely very wholesome
and kind thanks for subbing for two
months hey swirls
i just realized lee chess tells me how
much material i'm up
i hope this intimidates my opponent i'm
up 86 points
okay that's a sneaky move because um now
the queen is attacking the bishop
so i'll move back
oh maybe i could back rank mate but
really
a third rank mate this is basically
white's back rank
okay at least i'm not getting mated yet
these pawns are both past
but they are blockaded these pieces are
a bit stuck
i wish i could just like capture my own
piece
that would be nice what eight
seven oh i have the tournament open in a
new tab
no no no no withdraw okay i don't want
to start a game i want to finish
i'm gonna finish this game first
uh i don't wanna have like an accidental
simul
okay how do i do this
i could just move the oh this is a
threat
what is this oh let's just take
take on g5 um
i'm trying to open something up maybe f6
i'm just looking for tricks
g6
ah i'm kind of dead here knight h6 is
interesting kind of
but doesn't work here it takes takes
takes maybe that's the best
try i just have to open things up get to
the king
i was really dreaming of just bringing
my knight here
because that would if i could play here
this would be mate
but yeah only in my dreams
i have counseling rights
at least i can play this move
hoping that white doesn't see that
bishop b7 will lose a bishop
so i'm still up 85 points of material
but it's so sad casting is illegal
why my rooks haven't moved
it might depend like how the fen was set
up
like the custom position everything eric
oh thank you um
[Music]
what do i play
i have rook c8 i'm trying to maximize
resistance
i could take i can't castle here because
it's illegal
[Music]
oh maybe this move
yeah like all the other moves would lose
something like very easily
at least here i can can create some
safe haven for the king
if the pawn moves up i take the other
pawn
[Music]
put the rook into the game
ah
hey it's a fork let's go like king fork
coming back kind of
the king is so brave
my main my main attacking piece
i might not lose this
i might not lose this because i now i
win the thing
wow i i was hoping for queen g4 there
so now i i won material i'm up 91 points
uh and the queen and bishop my bishop's
still hanging
wait is this just mate
that's just meat because the h3 is
defended
so this rook actually proved to be
useful
wow i won that
and it's the funny thing is i think the
computer graph will say i was winning
the whole game
it's just going to be like a flat line
but we'll we'll
have to analyze thanks for the game
brigham
i was in deep trouble until i guess
starting with the king fork
led to the bishop discovered attack
um was almost a pin i mean my opponent
saw that
uh if takes there'd be the the pin but
taking is probably still a better move
because there's bishop g5 here
and this should still be winning for
white
but um
yeah i'm sure there are other ways oh
white was plus
one despite the fact i was up like 80 or
90 points
uh oh look at this graph
so it started the game yeah the thing is
wait d6 was a blunder
the stockfish is so savage mine is 99
insulting white's first move
um i'm pretty sure i could easily beat
stockfish from this position with whites
uh oh was white white had made in nine
that's so funny like initially
it'll say box winning and then
that's made in six for white
anyway i'm probably gonna have to put
that on youtube i was gonna put it on
youtube regardless like even if i lost
but
uh yeah i guess
winning made things more sweet um
and this is this is the thing about
engines like they don't understand
uh like long-term the fact that these
pieces
can't contribute like there's some
something with the evaluation algorithm
that counts material
and is blind to the fact that
these pieces don't matter so
okay hi to youtube oh chad is saying hi
to youtube
say hi back to chat oh i collected
level three emotes also hi to tagi
yeah we have the high youtube emotes
okay check and go wild for the next few
seconds